صاروخ سقط بعض ظهر ثلاثاء عند قريه
بولنديه قريبه من الحدود مع اوكرانيا
موديا بحياه مزارعين ومحدثا موجه ردود فعل
من بولندا ومن حلفائها الاطلسيين السلطات
ارسلت خبراء عسكريين الى مكان الحادث
لدراسه طبيعه صاروخ وقال الرئيس البولندي
انه على الارجح روسي الصنع لكن لا دلا الى
الان عن هويه الجهه المطلقه
في الوقت الراهن حول من اطلقه الصاروخ
سرعان ما رفعت بولندا مستوى بقواتها على
الرغم من ان الرئيس اعتبر سقوط الصاروخ
حدثا منزلا
قررنا زياده الاستعداد القتاليه لوحدات
مختارا من القوات المسلحه
معاهده حلف شمال الاطلسي والتي تسمح
باطلاق دعوه للتشاور عندما يشعر اي عضو في
الحلف بالتهديد بينما تتمهل بولندا في
اطلاق الاحكام لا يساوي الرئيس الاوكراني
شك حول الجهه المطلقه للصاروخ اليوم
كم مره قلنا لكم بان الدوله الارهابيه لن
تتوقف عند اراضي اوكرانيا الروس من جانبهم
وصفوا الانباء عن سقوط صاروخ الروسي في
بولندا
ومن قمه العشرين في بالي اعتبر الرئيس
الامريكي انه من غير مرجح ان يكون الصاروخ
قد اطلق من روسيا مؤكدا كامله الدعم
للحليب البولندي